welcome back to new rock stars i'm
jessica clements aka the nr she-hulk
here to break down episode 2 for you the
episode gets into jen really planting
her feet as she-hulk glk and h and how
shady their structure is but what i
really love is we get into emil blonsky
and his point of view to the duel of
harlem and the beat between himself and
hulk he's a great villain but i love
this point of view and i love him just
so much the last scene of this episode
gave us our lord and savior that is wong
so let's get into this with some details
that you might have missed titania is
what's referred to as a super influencer
which is hilarious because the term
super influencer super influencer
actually exists for top tier digital
influencers which titania absolutely is
she now has a twitter account with her
defacing she-hulk posters as her header
her bio says influencer icon global
lifestyle brand where kamala had her
youtube channel maybe titania as a
vlogger content creator influencer
honestly she might just have clothing
hauls and makeup tutorials i mean look
at her those headshots baby's a model or
actress we get different news outlets
covering the mayhem that ensued that day
at the courtroom kpvk and kzyo both
appeared in ant-man and wasp covering
ant-man aka giant man in the fbi room of
tvs we have news los angeles now that
could be affiliated with krxj channel 6
news in los angeles we last saw in iron
man 3 they share the similar colors the
headline below reads this which
absolutely could be the case this sort
of messy hollywood celebrity trope
moment additionally jovanna lara john
gregory and rachel brown each play the
news anchors and are actual news anchors
for abc 7's eyewitness news in los
angeles we get our first eyewitness and
reporter in the field if this guy looks
familiar to you he's in black lightning
playing the same character and
objectifying a female superhero my dude
stays typecasted they came up with the
name she hulk and thank god it wasn't
chick hulk but like bruce mentioned in
episode one you never have a choice with
these names we make it to the legalese
bar and grill love how green it is
legalese is the conventional way legal
documents are written so sort of a pun
either way this is where all the lawyers
hang out and drink we got the same sort
of stylized sports bar and she-hulk
comics also you know it's a bar of
lawyers with all those justice scales
nikki refers to jen as lady hulk
she-hulk girl hulk and in the comics jen
has been called chick hulk and girly
hulk before with it came nothing but
danger just don't get it twisted you
know what i'm saying with this new found
she-hulk courage she enters the bar to
cheers and applause completely stepping
past the hostess it's okay she didn't
want to see you guys anyways also the
coffee supplies on the bar hella cool
she's wearing a zip up hoodie because
she completely shredded her original
blazer hulking out in the courtroom the
song playing is celeste stop this flame
truly because you ain't stopping
she-hulk now jen mentions hoping that
the name doesn't stick and being a
derivative of the hulk which
unfortunately is exactly how she got her
name they created she-hulk from the
success of incredible hope the tv series
and with the bionic woman being so
popular it seemed like a good idea
marvel was afraid they'd introduced a
female version of hulk so they decided
to publish their own version so if any
movie made something similar marvel
would own the rights kind of like spider
woman it's just easier to trademark
before you know the phrase they ask for
permission before sorry laters is that
what they say later on jen says this to
nikki
i'm not no i did not go to law school
and rack up six figures in student loans
to become a vigilante that is for
billionaires and narcissists and adult
orphans for some reason probably
referring to people like steve rogers
thor most definitely tony stark i'd
argue natasha as well but i just
wouldn't necessarily call her a
narcissist you know when nikki suggests
being an avenger to jen jen says this
play me another clip do the avengers
offer health care
maternity leave a pension
are they even paid this got me thinking
yeah what are the benefits now in the
comics they got a lot according to the
avengers un charter and avengers annual
they got free health care they had
stipends a retirement fund access to
avenger vehicles weapons and a lot more
but in the mcu it's looking kind of
bleak so remember back in falcon and
winter soldier when sam was trying to
get a bank loan sam's got government
contract earnings so that could make a
lot also since he's a hero people are
inclined to help you you know the old
supe civilian benefits they have free
housing on a vendor's campus access and
security clearance to the avengers
facilities but most of what we know
about their actual benefits is still
sort of up in the air also people like
t'challa thor vision iron man don't
really need the benefits they had
endless money or were just a robot so
they probably overlooked people like
natasha clinton wanda who needed it her
d.a boss goes to talk to her and he's
pretty uncomfortable around she-hulk and
asks her to change to jennifer walters
because it's a serious conversation
these little microaggressions should be
noted because it's reinforcing that
she-hulk can physically be too much or
dominating or just make people uncomfy
and that's all [ __ ] when jen changes
from she-hulk to jennifer walter she's
intoxicated and mentions it's because of
the change of her metabolism that is
insane and dangerous she literally can
drink 30 bottles and get tipsy as
she-hulk but if she turns into jen she'd
be in the hospital insane and also
important to note our baby girl just got
fired for being a liability in the 2004
comic run it was the same exact thing
she and the avengers saved everyone on
earth which they concluded to be why the
jury had a speedy verdict if i had a
dollar for every time hulk was seen as a
liability i'd be rich either way it
seems like a very thin line easily
crossed for any superhero lawyer the
show's title introduced a little over
five minutes into the show like other
law shows better call saul allen mcbeal
lone order sorta does the same thing
though it really opens with in the
criminal justice system sexually based
offenses are considered spatially
heinous in new york city the dedicated
detectives who investigate these vicious
felonies are members of an elite squad
known as the special victims unit these
are their stores
also below where it says attorney at law
it changes to attorney for hire bruce
refers to jen that's fuzzball a lot and
in an interview with cnet with tatiana
maslany mentions mark ruffalo ad-libbed
and called her fuzzball because of her
hair during a take and it's stuck ever
since i think it's just really cute
someone please just call me fuzzball
quick hurry anyway
we get a shot of jen's apartment with
nikki we see the takeout food truly two
mini lamps you have four big windows
what do you need five lamps for and wine
bottles it's hard looking for a job and
i get it let's not forget the velvet
devil merlot bottles sitting on the
table washington state wine baby
represent they also put this devil wine
in there to torment boss i ain't buying
it it ain't mephisto well looking for
new jobs jen's on a site titled 10
off-beat jobs for a fresh start by kyle
wendt a lot of stuff to look at here you
can choose a sub genre fun movies find
ant-man which is probably where's waldo
style game cars norse mythology probably
in regards to thor avengers this is
self-explanatory insanity which the
article is currently under and world the
qr code leads you to the same one from
episode one to the marvel website the
actual recommended job on the site is to
be a swiss village mascot that town
right there is called burn in
switzerland the coat of arms of burn is
also a flag with a bear on it their
mascot is a bear so hence why you'd be
their bear mascot also the city does
resemble the city of moon night
certainly if you remember there's some
german signage it also fancies an alpine
village also from this shot of the
actual arts district of the small town
compared to the shot and moon knight
they covered the hungarian stores with
german names so this could be a little
village and burn just a possibility but
empty i think you're right also remember
burn 2000 the science conference where
tony hooked up with maya was also there
as an advertisement don't miss out on
these cool iron man 3's dear god it has
tony's heart symbol above it also this
indicates there was an iron man one and
two sneaker if you're thinking dang i
gotta get on those quick adidas did a
collab with marvel and made stark shoes
so i'm sure you can still get them for
related articles we have man fights with
metal claws and a bar brawl how is this
not about wolverine i repeat this is
absolutely about wolverine who else
would it be this literally happened in
the first x-men movie why there is a
giant statue of man sticking out of the
ocean thank god it's been finally
addressed this is referring to tiamat
and eternals so now it's a little after
eternals they're aware of what happens
so the timeline for this show is ever
changing head writer jessica gao said it
was a little after shang chi but
marvel's page on disney plus puts it
right after moon night i think we'll get
more evidence as the show continues to
where it really lands either way these
writers are truly just the best i love
this keep teasing us go ahead we get a
glimpse of jen's phone the wallpaper is
captain america's ass bliss no date
though you know for timeline reasons
we're first introduced to jen's dad
morris walters played by mark lynn baker
who's been on a ton of law order and
ally mcbeal and jen's mom elaine walters
played by tess mallis kincaid who played
a judge on bluff city law just to say
every actor has probably been on a law
show at least once in their life we meet
uncle tucker played by michael h cole
who was also the acting coach on wand
division black widow and guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 cousin chad played by
nicholas cerrillo and up melanie played
by candace rose aka chrissy's mom and
stranger things and aunt rebecca played
by elizabeth becca and unless there's
two aunt rebeccas in that world that
could be bruce's mom rebecca banner
which is weird i don't know why she's so
quiet oh she's allowed to be quiet
everyone's allowed to be quiet i guess
but that's bruce's mom let me paint a
picture for you you're a dude you're
watching she-hulk and you're thinking
what can i do to give myself a glow-up
without getting hulk blood involved glad
you asked i've got an answer it's
geology
geology is a 13 time award-winning
skincare company that creates simple
effective personalized skin care
products see the link in today's video's
description click that and take a 30
second quiz tell geology about your skin
and their team of dermatologists would
design a regimen just for you that ships
directly to your door knock knock who's
there it's geology
their products are great for whatever
you're worried about acne dark eye
circles or wrinkles you'll be send a
30-day trial see that's easy to
incorporate into your routine whether
you're new to skincare or a seasoned
expert you know how dudes of new rock
stars always look fresh-faced i'm
talking zac brandon and tommy no matter
how many straight hours of nerd stuff
they've been watching this is their
secret it's geology specifically their
fancy eye cream geology makes it easy to
take care of your skin no need to become
an amateur dermatologist they're
offering a crazy deal right now you can
get it for 70
off oh my gosh 70 off on their 30-day
five-piece trial kit head to geology.com
to get 70 off your 30-day trial when you
use the code rockstar 70 or just click
the link below that's geology.com promo
code rockstar 70 to save 70 off on your
30-day trial take it away jessica jen's
mom mentions a nice young man she wants
her to meet who wants to be a superhero
one day and is super young jessica gao
confirmed on twitter it's her assistant
you song lou but on the closed captions
it says yusuf so it could be yusuf abbas
yusuf appeared in civil war marvel
snapshots number one as the helper who
loved superheroes like the avengers and
later developed some mutant powers to
answer walter's question brought up at
the dinner table that hawkeye guy what
happens to those arrows of his i mean
does he go around and collect them when
he's done hawkeye at times will go back
and retrieve his arrows more so if he
runs out like in hawkeye the series and
in the first avengers he ran out of
arrows he retrieved one from the shitari
he just killed and used his last
arrowhead to make it into a grappling
hook so it's not beyond him to go
recover lost arrows but as for the trick
arrows that have already been used the
arrow shafts that are left behind i yeah
could be dangerous i guess if you
tripped and fell onto it but that's the
dodc's job to clean it up when jen's dad
says you didn't even destroy a city in
reference to hulks notorious hulking out
and destroying everything i could yeah
break down every time hulk destroyed a
city or something but i'll just do a
quick squirrel right here
[Applause]
all right the lawyer bar is playing ally
mcbeal look at it um that's all
like in the comics holden approaches jen
for this phenomenal job offer at the bar
and with the same amount of little
respect he's so shady this look that he
gives a bartender
again i just want to say if holden is
orchestrating all of this i said it
first now i'm not saying he's anything
wild but let's keep in mind some folks
could be scrolls there's also a little
statue behind jen this isn't quite the
lady justice statue she's holding a
candle it looks like a lot of statues
like this will probably be seen
throughout the show like this one at glk
h and we've arrived at glk and h it's
massive and jen's looking damn confident
that is until she doesn't know how to
open this door she-hulk would have just
ripped that off the handles holden
mentions how eccentric superhumans are
appearing more and more in marvel comics
superhuman was applied to those way
beyond normal human physical conditions
altogether they're super humans which
we've got into in she-hulk enhanced
individuals the dodc refers to them as
this and miss marvel inhumans which
we've seen in black bolt and multiverse
and madness a38 and mutants brandon and
i do a great big q on this and how
classifications could work in the mcu so
go ahead and just click back on over to
that holden also mentions that he wants
jen showing up to work and at court as
she hulk the complete opposite of what
he wanted in the comics in the comics he
wanted her to only work as jennifer a
sharp returning with a keen focused mind
he's just trying to use her he's hella
sketchy take a look at all those comics
in the 2004 she-hulk run stu cicero
worked in the basement of glk and h
monitoring all the marvel comic books
that people use for research this could
be our stew and this is where you refer
back to for research it's like a library
we meet pug played by josh agara i love
pug not only is he super supportive and
loves jen in the comics he's clearly
very funny and just kind of gross here
poke has a wild history paying for
school by being a bouncer he was saved
by spider-man and he's just an awesome
bestie if you look closer in the basket
we have a plaque for jennifer walter's
name the same cup we saw in episode 1
the cu later litigator and office
supplies oh and sorry i almost forgot
about the poop map god i love him so
much we find out jen's first case is the
parole of emil blonsky aka abomination
quickly let's go down memory lane with
abomination emil blonsky was a formal
special ops met up with thunderbolt ross
who injected him with the super soldier
serum he tries to take on hulk loses
then he took on hulk's blood and
transformed into abomination he then
tried to kill hulk in the duel of harlem
and lost he's been mentioned since
almost being on the avengers and we've
seen wong releasing him out of prison
just to kick his ass he also
specifically wants to retain jen as his
attorney that's important to note and
also very suspicious we finally get to
the dodc's super max prison the cube
it's kind of like the raft which we saw
in civil war but this i suspect is in
cali the death valley-ish area seen as
in the comics this version was in nevada
this is also where the clandestines are
sent to in miss marvel episode 4. at the
entrance it says department of damage
control super max prison we see their
dodc sigil this is all legit the entry
guard foley is played by matt scholler
but on his hat the symbol doesn't match
the dodc sigil his hat reads at the
bottom fbp ca fbp stands for federal
bureau of prisons so this one's the
california division the top says
superhuman federal penitentiary with the
symbol looking like the us apartment
justice logo i think it's suspicious
that the guards uniform doesn't even
slightly resemble the dod sees could the
supermax prison outsource their guards
right now i think the big cheese
overseeing this is val rather than the
dsdcc she's like the point of contact if
you will we get a little call back here
the signs of the lambs you're gonna
serve me up with some fatherly internet
nice
this is a prison when hannibal discloses
how he ate the census taker's liver with
some fava beans and a nice chianti
we see emil blonsky played by tim roth
and yes it's the same cell we see in
chiang chi truly i go crazy in something
like that and i'm glad wong was sneaking
him out in the trailer when emil blonsky
turns into abomination he hits his head
on the ceiling triggering a red alarm
and wave of red lights the same alarm
sets off when jen steps over the yellow
line it's probably like a sensory alarm
imagine the game operation if you will
but also this doesn't even phase a meal
we also see a painting of the sun
setting over an ocean and maybe he
painted it but the calming ocean
presence and sun's getting real low is
truly smart hulk 101 he's in mexico
doing yoga by the beach settling with
his inner hulk him and a meal aren't so
different and it's mentioned later that
hulk and him exchange letters briefly so
maybe hulk gave him some advice
abomination chooses not to change and
i'm not trying to be a wild person and
connect this to everything but i mean
come on if this entire game is a game of
chess val probably persuaded emil to
reconcile with the idea of bruce banner
ushered him to hire his cousin to
represent him bonus she's a good lawyer
she'll probably win but along the way
will turn back into abomination when
easily angered by jenner bruce because
when he even mentions bruce there look
at his eyes his pure resentment then
gets picked up by the hands of val then
watch val be his parole officer emile
mentioned he's been talking to seven
people within the prison pen pal program
and wants to run away with them on their
purchase property for him i support this
polygamy also i think we see them in the
she-hulk trailer you see jen near a meal
cell and behind her are seven people
standing wearing white tops and i think
crown so yeah i think that's his seven
partners i'm also like girls you saw
abomination you saw what he did to
harlem why are you over him like ah
whatever speaking of which they
mentioned the duel of harlem when
abomination went wild toe-to-toe with
hulk and the incredible hulk but what i
really love here is emil's sadness and
retelling his point of view of
everything and truly how the us
government let him down and hulk was the
threat which referred back to my earlier
scroll of all the things hulk has
destroyed in the mcu to see how much of
a threat he kinda is but truly hope
didn't really suffer the same as
abomination hulk is kind of a hero now
an abomination is a prisoner it's worth
pondering once we're out of the prison
and back at jen's apartment she calls
bruce to give him the 401. smart hulk is
on the sikarian class a superior craft
why is it to see his son is it the
further study of the city i think he's
been back after thor ragnarok and we
just haven't seen it because how else we
have brought back the sakar gems what we
saw on the first episode this courier
ship is oh my god it's insane okay so on
it we see the mighty honk behind him
from episode one some binders and
folders on the shelf the big binder used
to follow hulk's evolution why would he
need that a lot of the same tech from
the basement lab in mexico also hulk get
your damn feet off the desk you're a
hulk not an animal i also like the nod
at hulk saying he's a completely
different person now that fight was so
many years ago i'm a completely
different person now yeah yeah ain't
edward norton fighting a meal my dude
when we see the news it's k-d-a-j los
angeles news 10 who are the same people
outside jen's apartment in the trailer
footage has been released of abomination
fighting wong and xiang chi at the
golden daggers club maybe that night in
particular was popular to record the
fights or because of the aftermath
someone released said footage but this
might have also been wong in
abomination's first time fighting in the
ring or in public if this just now got
out this time we close she-hulk with her
theme song but we've got a few courtroom
illustrations we get nikki and her
drinking we get the glk and h superhuman
law division with her nikki pug holden
and who we know as malory book played by
renee ellis goldsberry who was in
hamilton mallory and she-hulk in the
comics started to hate each other
mallory just kind of sucked she was mean
and super disrespectful to she-hulk all
the time and she was the best attorney
until she hulk showed up she hold cold
in the fridge for her mom while she
vacuums and her dad pointing at a broken
light insinuating to fix it the poop
here diagram given to her by pug with
nikki and she-hulk the mid-credit scene
is jen doing every bit of heavy lifting
work for her dad since chad is
absolutely incapable of helping and
that's everything that i spotted in the
second episode of she-hulk follow me on
instagram and twitter at lulu underscore
clemens follow new rockstars subscribe
to new rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
free blonski
[Music]
you